today for our daily cancellation i will
be canceling all of the cancellers of
the british pop star
uh adele adele is the latest white
celebrity to get herself into trouble
for the imaginary sin of cultural
appropriation
now the singer posted a picture of
herself sporting bantu knots which is a
traditional african hairstyle
featuring multiple buns or knots adele
has
presumably worn many hairstyles over the
years all of those styles have origin
somewhere it's doubtful that any of them
originate in modern britain
is she supposed to check an encyclopedia
every time she wants to put her hair up
to ensure that she doesn't fashion it in
a way that bears similarity to
hairstyles worn by non-white people
apparently so racial justice demands it
it's really not so much to ask when you
think about it
so as as cities burn in our country
deals with multiple major crises at once
our friends on the left you know still
had time to worry about the way a woman
across the ocean decided to fashion her
hair
ernest owens a self-described
award-winning journalist and rich guy on
the forbes list
spoke out valiantly on this important
issue he said if 2020 couldn't get any
more bizarre adele is giving us bantu
knots
and cultural appropriation that nobody
asked for
this officially marks all of the top
women and pop as problematic
now owens an alleged grown man is
himself appropriating
from 19 year old pink hair gender
studies majors by calling an utterly
innocuous thing
problematic also i didn't realize that
people had to
ask for a certain hairstyle before we're
allowed to wear it
like who who who should we ask before we
wear
are we supposed to be asking ernest
owens every morning as you comb your
hair
just shoot a quick message to owens
explain what style you're thinking of
going with for the day and you know wait
for him to give you the go-ahead i mean
he has to ask you to wear it before
you're allowed to wear it other
luminaries like jameel hill last seen
while claiming that the united states is
analogous to nazi germany you might
remember that from last week
um also swooped in to deliver a scolding
to a woman who
wore too many buns in her hair i mean i
assume that is the problem here it's too
many buns not the bun
itself because ancient greeks wore buns
yes i actually did look this up
um i mean it's safe to assume even that
you know many people in ancient times
probably wore hairstyles that included
multiple buns
so the age-old question how many buns
can adele have
before she becomes racist what is the
bun
threshold now i counted nine visible
buns yes i did count
would she be racist with just five buns
what about six
and by the way are we certain that the
nine or ten bun style originates with
african women
i mean do we know that no other culture
anywhere on earth ever thought of doing
that many buns
these are questions that the
appropriation police never answer
can't answer left-wing bloggers also
leapt into action uh thankfully a writer
for the website the root
wrote a lengthy article on the issue of
adele's hair and she lamented that the
singer you know would do something so
callous as to put her hair in a bun
when adele has been says the writer up
to this point
among the least problematic faves of the
caucasian persuasion
now one might argue that labeling
someone a least
problematic fave of a certain race
is far more racist than wearing too many
buns in your hair but what do i know
rebecca fishbein over at jezebel proved
that she's one of the good white people
by
joining the pylon quoting from an
instagram commenter this is a comment
from the from the person on instagram
apparently this is a good point
black women are discriminated against
for wearing cultural hairstyles like
bantu knots and locks but white people
are not
that's not fair and that's why people
are pissed off
but isn't adele being discriminated
against right now
has any black woman ever been criticized
in publication publications across
the entire globe for wearing her hair in
a bun and even if some black women have
been discriminated against for wearing
the hairstyle
why exactly does that mean other people
can't wear it
we're told that some people of one race
are discriminated against for wearing
something and therefore people of
another race
shouldn't wear it but we seem to have
leapfrogged over a few of the steps in
this logical progression because there's
no apparent connection
between the premise and the conclusion
and no one has ever tried to explain
what the connection would be
the problem here and the reason why the
appropriation police can never quite
explain
what appropriation is and why it's wrong
and why any of this matters
is that the whole concept is meaningless
i mean you would think that the people
who loved to see everything as fluid and
on a spectrum
and a human construct would understand
that culture is by definition the most
fluid human construct of all
culture is simply the customs traditions
arts and institutions of any group of
people
and those customs traditions arts and
institutions are always
evolving and changing and they're in
constant exchange
with other cultures in this era of
global connectivity
that process is in hyperdrive it happens
quicker
and more efficiently this is why even if
it made sense to accuse one culture of
stealing
you know a style from another culture
which it doesn't because
theft deprives the victim of the thing
being stolen
but nobody's being prevented from
wearing buns just because adele was
wearing them
you know as if there's some sort of
scarcity of buns and adele is hogging
more than her chair
but even so now even if it made sense we
still couldn't identify
who is actually guilty of stealing from
whom humans have been
making culture in some form or another
for tens of thousands of years
for you know for most trends and
fashions therefore it's not possible to
identify a definitive
date or place of origin even if you
could
what influenced the person who came up
with it and what
influenced the influences of that person
and so on and so on and so on
this problem was illustrated recently
when a white business owner in seattle
was forced to
issue an apology for wearing dreadlocks
which supposedly appropriated from
african culture too but
dreadlocks have been worn all throughout
history by people of all different races
and cultures and traditions
vikings wore dreadlocks hindus war still
wear dreadlocks
who owns them answer nobody
because style is not a thing that can be
owned
we might as well say that whoever first
baked a loaf of bread
now owns the concept of bread and only
the direct descendants of that person
are allowed to experience its joys which
are considerable
of course you know i'm trying to engage
with the concept of cultural
appropriation honestly and logically
which means i'm missing the point
it is not supposed to make sense it is
simply supposed to be accepted and
obeyed
it is just another means of controlling
people and sowing division and discord
in a society
that i would say already has a surplus
of both
[Music]
and that is why adele's cancellers are
cancelled and and everyone
who uses the phrase cultural
appropriation unironically is also
cancelled
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative
outlets in the entire country if you
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
like and then subscribe to our youtube
channel so you don't miss out on any of
our content